I've lived in Washington now for 44
years
and that's a lot of folly to witness hi
I'm Nick Gillespie with Matt Welch and
we're talking today with George Will The
Washington Post columnist this week
panelist and author of many books
including statecraft of Soulcraft what
government does men at work the craft of
baseball and most recently one man's
America the pleasures and provocations
of our singular nation born in 1941 and
raised in the college environs of
Champaign Urbana Illinois will holds a
PhD in political science from Princeton
a school once operated by one of the
very worst of all American President
Woodrow Wilson and his dissertation was
titled beyond the reach of majorities
closed questions in the open society
we're gonna ask you tough questions
about your dissertation later a former
staffer for Colorado Republican senator
Gordon allit he has taught politics at
Michigan State worked at national review
and received the Pulitzer Prize for
commentary in 1977 Wall Street Journal
has called him perhaps the most powerful
journalist in America and he has the
distinction of having been attacked as a
pseudo intellectual in the pages of
Doom's Barry back when people actually
still read that comic strip and of
having been praised by Cramer on
Seinfeld not for his intelligence but
for his clean scrubbed look welcome
George well thank you it's the first
time my children ever took me seriously
I could imagine appeared on Seinfeld the
nurse said I was cute
yes he liked your appearance very much
but not your brain so in 2011 you
discussed in in your Washington Post
column a rather obscure track called the
Declaration of Independence
how libertarian politics can fix what's
wrong with America and you wrote these
incurably upbeat journalist with Reason
magazine believed that not even
government try as it will can prevent
onrushing social improvement America you
continued is moving in the Libertarians
direction not because they have won an
argument but because government and the
sector's it dominates has made them have
made themselves ludicrous this has open
binds to the libertarian argument is it
correct to say that you yourself over
the years are inclining more in
returning direction as well yes for
several reasons the first is that I've
lived in Washington now for 44 years and
that's a lot of folly to witness up
close and whatever confidence and
optimism one felt toward the central
government when I got here in January
1st 1970 is pretty much dissipated at
the hands of the government second I
participate although I'm 72 and too old
to learn very much I do participate in
the changing technological assumptions
give you an example when I was growing
up and I wanted to hear the songs of the
day Bill Haley and the Comets and the
platters and all that stuff I would turn
on the radio and hope that the disc
jockey I was listening to would play
three or four of the songs I wanted to
hear in the next hour my daughter and
other children want to hear their songs
they just could be internet and they
have 50,000 but I wanted a cup of coffee
I went to a coffee shop and ordered a
cup of coffee now you go to Starbucks or
somewhere and you have a mind-boggling
number of choices and choice just seems
more natural more built into the
socialism so what does that have to do
with government or your assumptions
about government well first of all
government operates on one size fits all
because that suits the bureaucratic
method and impulse which is Empire
building and manifest destiny on the
part of every bureaucracy to maximize
its mission you can see it at everything
from the Secret Service no president can
be safe enough to Obamacare you've said
previously that John McCain was kind of
helpful in your evolution in a more
libertarian direction talk a little bit
about that well the mccain feingold law
did something that i had never occurred
to me even Congress would have the
audacity and effrontery to do or that
the Supreme Court would ratify which it
largely did at first and that is
Congress which is to say incumbent
laterz passed laws limiting the content
timing and quantity of political speech
about incumbent legislators and this a
past which shouldn't have surprised me
but it did and was as I say ratified by
the Supreme Court so I mean that that
was kind of the the final moment right
your Kronstadt moment or something where
you gave up completely on large
government as an instrument of that was
part of it that I also I'm a reader and
I read Mansur Olson and I read Jonathan
Roush demo sclerosis where he applied
some of Olsen's insights about how
interest groups fastened like barnacles
on a ship of state and eventually
immobilized the ship and make reform
almost impossible let's let's talk about
this in context of statecraft as
Soulcraft which was published in 83 and
it was kind of I mean you had been in
the public eye for a decade or more but
this was kind of a big statement and
among other things you wrote caustically
if the differences are actually the
similarities between liberals and
conservatives at the time and you were
talking about people like FDR and Ronald
Reagan you wrote I will do many things
for my country but I will not pretend
that the careers of say Ronald Reagan
and Franklin Roosevelt involves serious
philosophical differences specifically
you fault at both groups for believing
that the inner life of citizens are and
you talked about our sentiments manners
and moral opinions were none of the
government's business so you were saying
that FDR Ronald Reagan meant it when he
said that he was an FDR Democrat and
that the problem with them is that they
left people alone too much no what
Ronald Reagan said I'm an FDR Democrat
not a Great Society Lyndon Johnson
Democrat that Ronald Reagan never
assaulted and never promised to assault
in any fundamental way the social safety
net it was when government got into the
business of saying who should live where
who should think what the Great Society
agenda of comprehensive social
engineering
that Reagan got off the bandwagon state
craft is Soulcraft to read by dozens was
began as the Godkin lectures at Harvard
and three lectures in 1981 the subtitle
is what government does not what
government should do but what government
cannot help but do any regime by its
structure of laws is affirming certain
values and discouraging certain vices if
you have a free-market laissez-faire
society a market Society affirms certain
values choice freedom self-reliance
sanctity of contract promise keeping all
the rest and therefore when you choose
your regime you are choosing to affirm
and nurture and encourage a certain
character that's why what I said
government cannot not be in any business
other than the sole craft business do
you still believe that I do and I think
you do too
well yeah let me ask us in in the column
that you had written about our book the
Declaration of Independence you you've
noted the essence of libertarian
political thought is the common sensical
principle that before government
interferes with the freedom of the
individual and of individuals making
consensual transactions in the market in
markets it ought to have a defensible
reason for doing so it usually does not
now you're just talking about
mccain-feingold you're the entitlement
state you've been on an arch critic of
things like Medicare and Social Security
you're you are against war in Syria you
became a critic of the Iraq invasion I
mean you that the beads are piling up
where your sack a government can't do
these things right where are some places
that the government still should be
limiting human interaction or or you
know where is it defensible to say no
actually people can't do this
fewer and fewer as you say obviously
there are neighborhood effects of
pollution and neighborhood effects of
noise neighborhood effects of all sorts
where the government goes astray is when
the government decides that it is going
to allocate wealth and opportunity and
that's almost entirely what the
government does nowadays the tax code
for example is as chairman Dave camp of
Michigan chairman of the House Ways and
Means Committee says the tax code is
longer than the Bible without the good
news because it is entirely rent-seeking
it is more than the appropriations
process the tax code is how the
government allocates favors and we reach
a point and this is sort of a
systemically important point and why I
go to the tax code we may have reached a
point where the tax code is so
complicated it cannot be reformed that
is because if you say let's start over
as camp and Baucus have tried to do they
said okay we're gonna have a blank slate
we're gonna wipe out all the exemptions
credits deductions all the rest and it's
up to you people to defend them and
we'll put them back in the problem is if
you start with a blank slate you're not
picking one fight with every American
you're picking five fights with every
American and the system can't handle it
you get just to go back to that kind of
man sir Olson or demo sclerosis model is
is it impossible then to separate the
barnacles from the hull and are we just
going down and you know what I mean are
we sinking or how do you what do you do
now we're not sinking we're slowing down
that is it's very hard to move the ship
and it slows down in terms of economic
growth because you're allocating wealth
and opportunity in political rather than
efficient ways and this has cumulatively
a terrific drag on economic growth the
sort of the philosophical basis of
statecraft is Soulcraft for what we were
talking about just earlier could be seen
couldn't it as okay government is an
instrument of morality and once people
politicians and commentators have that
feeling then that helps the removal of
limitations in the LBJ way saw David
Brooks I think was citing statecraft of
soulcraft the other day as one of his
periodic Jeremih ads against
libertarianism yes so how do you square
those kind of impulses well here's how
strict pure libertarians say because the
government can back its tastes with the
police power it shouldn't have tastes
the argument of statecraft is Soulcraft
is that's all very well but you again
what government does government is going
to have laws it's going to legalize
certain things prescribe certain things
encourage certain things you have to
pick you have to choose and unless you
have the most severe sort of
Nightwatchman
state and we're not going to have that
by the way by severe you mean totally
freaking awesome it's not going to
happen I mean I wrote the other day that
if we could tax Americans cognitive
dissonance we could balance the budget
that the American people want all kinds
of incompatible things they're human
beings and they want a high services low
tax omnipresent
I'm the Provident cheap welfare state do
do they get that in a place like Texas
there's a new book out by Erica Grider
which is pretty interesting she's a
liberal who writes for Texas Monthly or
the Texas observer and she talks about
how you know Texas as opposed to
California's essentially that it's it's
low tax low service high opportunity
it's not it's not a libertarian state
but doesn't Texas show that actually
maybe Americans would settle for
something you know is is the vision of
the country between California and Texas
and Texas is winning right now this is
why we have federalism there are two
reason to have federalism first you're
more apt to have three or four or five
smart governors and you already have a
smart president at any time so you
dispersed decision making and
experimenting beyond that Texas we can
now practice under federalism what the
late Daniel Boorstin great a historian
and librarian of Congress called
entrepreneurial federalism that is what
the states compete for mobile businesses
for SNAs wonderful essay on this in one
of his three volumes of his history
called the Americans he said it started
with divorce that Indiana said we're
gonna have easier divorces than anyone
else and then the Dakotas that know now
we're gonna have Dakota a divorcee isn't
finally Nevada got in the act Nevada
said like the Comstock Lode is petered
out the money's gone to San Francisco we
got more sheep than people here what can
we do and they said we're gonna have
really easy divorce and by the way while
you're here waiting was six weeks or
whatever it is you can gamble hence Las
Vegas hence Reno has all the rest we see
this all the time the president if I
could mr. Obama the other day went to
like Knox College in Galesburg on on art
gave speech in which he said two
particularly riveting things he said
just terrible that Maytag pulled up from
Illinois and went to Mexico no one said
yeah mr. president that's because your
friends and the labor unions chased him
out about a few sentences later he says
but wonderful things are happening
Airbus is going to the European
consortium going to build aircraft in
Alabama
well why they go to Alabama because it's
a right-to-work state you do you think
somebody like Obama doesn't understand
that this juncture or
you know I or is he is he you know just
kind of dissembling this is a man who
says ATMs and airport ticket kiosks
cause unemployment we had this argument
a long time ago
about whether or not automation
automating the Ford plant will mean no
one will be able to buy Ford cars we
surely we've had that argument but it
hasn't percolated through to the Hyde
Park section of Chicago do you feel like
speaking of like that economic arguments
that we have back slid a lot especially
since the financial meltdown of 2008
refighting people are talking about
reregulate announcer today's and
magazines where they used to talk about
deregulating airlines has there been a
backsliding on economic discussion in
this country I don't think so yeah I I
don't think so no III think that any
American who's on the board of a school
museum Orchestra anything with an item
now identified roughly with one tenth of
one percent of American right but I
speak for the 1% knows that when you
have economic growth of three percent or
more everything's happy in America when
you have two percent protracted ly
everything's sad in America 1% 1/2
percent makes all the difference in the
world
the American political system is not
used to doing what it has been doing for
a decade now that is allocating scarcity
we're used to allocating surplus and
it's much easier to do that talk about
what are the roots of that because one
of the things that's interesting about
your reading your work over the past
several decades is you were as tough on
george w bush as you were as you have
been on barack obama or on you know kind
of broadly based liberals and democrats
if economic growth started slowing down
in the you know the middle of the 24 the
first decade of the 21st century what
were the policies that Bush was pushing
that helped contribute to that or
Republicans more broadly and and have
they fully kind of internalized their
role in this kind of scarcity America no
I don't think they have
those people have internalized it who
asked the simple question of every
proposed policy how does it contribute
to or subtract from economic growth
that's everything now we have an ongoing
national tragedy we're losing a
generation now you have what happened
what percentage of young people are now
living with their parents say 18 to 28
something like that
you know and the real tragedy is for the
parents I've got four children at home
I've dodged that bullet but no I mean
the the sheer waste you you began by
quoting me is saying about how hard it
is for government to stop innovation and
growth the American people are prodigies
at wealth creation it's hard to stop
them we're industrious educated we have
Continental market we're mobile people
things aren't working in Michigan we
moved to Texas yet still the cumulative
weight of lots of little policies so
what were some of those policies in
particular that Bush or the Republicans
kind of layered on top of the cake well
first of all the regulations I was asked
to come up and talk to the house members
about two years ago and I said what's
the what should we do I said first of
all pledge you will not publish the
Federal Register I can do it anymore I'm
not gonna have any more regulations then
and this is a something that Romney
endorsed and others have any major
regulation understood as one with a
hundred million dollar impact on the
economy has to be voted on but their
fingerprints on this it'll really work
wonders but that did happen with things
like dodd-frank it more recently and in
the back sarbanes-oxley the Medicare
person I mean it's not a regulation but
the Medicare prescription drug expansion
well medically no you know what made the
Medicare prescription drug particularly
pernicious and particularly Republican
was that it was the first major
expansion of an entitlement without a
dedicated funding they just said well
we'll make it up as we go along but
borrow it from the Chinese what what's
going through the Republican mine
that when they're when they're doing
something well in the in the pithy
statement of Dick Cheney Ronald Reagan
proved the deficits don't matter he
didn't do any such thing but the only
prove that to Dick Cheney right and in
fact deficits don't matter politically
the American people talk about balanced
budget they don't care about a balanced
budget at all and in fact what what
deficits have done and and Reagan gets
some of the demerits for this deficits
have made big government cheap we're
giving the American people a dollars
worth of government charging them sense
filler and America say we can live with
that there's a new generation of
politicians who are arising that
actually do talk about this stuff Justin
Amash Rand Paul they talk about actually
cutting government and tackling this
problem they try to win elections and
these are the people that would that you
were speaking of when you said well a
couple months ago that the most
interesting thing in American politics
since last fall's election was the
Republican Party getting more
interesting becoming more heterodox on
foreign policy and domestic policy yes
talk about that what do you find
interesting about these guys well first
of all they they begin with a principle
that one you basically read me enunciate
II which is before it's not a radical
principle it says before the government
interferes with freedom or privacy it
ought to have a compelling reason that's
all just tell me your reason when you
start like that all kinds of things
happen because 98% of what government
does it does for factions what the
founders called factions which are those
who are not public spirited but private
spirited who are trying to bend public
power to private advantage and if you
start with that simple principle there's
no end the time you can ask that on a
given day as to what's going on in
Washington
what what explains that if they appeal
and and obviously you know the Rand
Paul's the Mike Lee is the Justin Amash
is Thomas Massey's of the world they're
they're gaining energy and momentum but
so far they're a fraction of the
Republican Party much less the
electorate why are why are they striking
a chord with people and if in fact you
know Americans like government on the
cheap you know how how how far can they
go with that well it we'll see how far
they can go but this is the argument
basically for a balanced budget
amendment to the Constitution it's the
public choice argument that the
incentive to deliver benefits now and
defer the costs on to the unborn and
hence unconsenting future generations is
irresistible the public choice argument
is powerful and gaining more strength
why the libertarian impulse now partly
they've got as the government gets
bigger it becomes more comprehensively
annoying and the annoyances add up but
beyond that there is a great sense that
Americans lost its energy it's a kind of
kind of sagging taking over the country
that you look around you see even where
we're supposed to spend money we're not
spending money give you an example
I traveled between Washington New York
all the time by train I thank the people
of Boise for subsidizing the Acela I
don't know why they do it but he'd do it
and I appreciate it but I don't want to
live forever I want to live long enough
to go through Union Station and Penn
Station where all the escalators are
working at the same time they are just
awful this the shabby tadi shop worn
down up the heels but by your nature of
American public infrastructure but we
shouldn't be spending money on yes we
should who's we Kemosabe in that in that
who's the show you ensure the public
should spend on genuine public goods and
in recent columns you've talked about
things like I mean you talk about the
sequester obviously you're in favor of
cutting the over
federal budget yes it is now but you
talk about you you actually are critical
of the sequester for the effect that's
having on say the National Institutes of
Health correct what are lay out some of
the you know some of the things that you
think the government actually should be
spending money on well I'm a Henry Clay
Abraham Lincoln central Illinois Whig I
believe in canals on the Illinois and a
lot of other states project if it broke
when they plunge to too enthusiastically
ended public works but yes I roads we
used to be my dear and best friend Pat
Moynihan said we used to be a nation
that celebrated people who got things
done now we celebrate people who stop
things from getting done happen
spent most of his long career in
Washington try and get the West Side
Highway changed in New York great
potential urban scape that would be a
great beauty to Manhattan can't get it
done because there's some wretched fish
in the river but here I guess is there a
kind of algorithm and I guess there
isn't but of you know you if the New
Deal ends up giving us the Great Society
you know okay then you have somebody
like Ronald Reagan say okay I don't want
the great Sutter I want the New Deal but
then he pursues policies through deficit
spending that actually then jack up the
Great Society where do you get back to a
point once you grant that well yeah the
West Side Highway or Amtrak should be
run by the federal if the New Deal of
necessity had to in the end give us the
Great Society it is because the New Deal
gave rise to a new class not capital and
labor but regulators and regulated
that's what America's become we're now
generating enormous numbers of lawyers
happily there's a collapse in the law
school admissions so there may be a
corrective at work here but we have
produced an enormous number of people
who think they are entitled to rule who
are trained to rule which is to say
trained to
administer the regulatory state and
arguably absent the New Deal we wouldn't
have had the regulatory state which gave
rise to this class that decided it could
fix Bedford Stuyvesant you're talking
about foreign policy earlier this it
seems since Reagan and perhaps before
but definitely since Reagan there is a
Republican culture of being sort of
strong and barrel-chested on defense and
then you have this kind of Justin Amash
Rand Paul wing which is talking
strikingly different about military
spending and about civil liberties about
due process and things like that can a
modern Republican policy a party
tolerate that kind of growth of a more
skeptical humble type of foreign policy
approaches well it it better because the
long comes the president says or let's
let's have a fourth intervention at
least let's bomb Syria and eighty
percent of the countries is let's not no
8020 issues don't come along that often
and you want to be on the right side of
those remember it was a Republican who
warned against the military-industrial
complex
January 1961 farewell address Dwight
Eisenhower who knew a thing or two about
war having been in a few Eisenhower
spurned those in his cabinet and they
were loud and Legion who said we have to
help the French and VN beyond food we
said no we don't actually
quemo mat-su the French British Israeli
adventure and Suez he brought it to a
halt he just stopped it using our
financial power the Hungarian Revolution
which we perhaps the improvidently
encouraged but
Eisenhower should be that as it may that
did not obligate us to intervene we
can't do it can't get there from here so
there is a tradition of Republican
restraint and and it's all the more
impressive because what caused
Eisenhower to take off his uniform leave
shave and run for president was the fear
that the Republican Party would be taken
over by Bob Taft and Taft was too
isolationist to use the problematic term
although in tax case that may have been
accurate it may have been but Eisenhower
felt devoted to the Alliance NATO and
all the rest and so here was Eisenhower
who ran for president because he was
more interventionist and
internationalist than part of his party
but who still had a had a fairly
well-developed sense of restraint how
much you know to take it down from a
kind of atmosphere of rhetoric and war
to political reality how much of it is
that the Republican Party became the
hawkish party because they started
winning the south where a lot of
military spending was done and the
Democrats have been more hawkish when
they ran the south I don't think that's
it you know I think it has more to do
with the intellectuals the party Pat
Moynihan said in about 1980 he said
something momentous happened in the
1970s the Republican Party became the
party of ideas now the good part of that
was they were the ideas of Milton
Friedman about parlor ends Society the
Austrian economists Hayek all the rest
and in foreign policy however they
became the party of first of all
stopping the slide in the later stages
of the Cold War which was real and
dangerous I think when the Cold War
ended I think some conservatives
suffered an acute bout of 30s Envy
it was a wonderful clarity to the
thirty-day Franco
Stalin Hitler Mussolini bad guys
certifiable clear bed it looked bad they
were bad and they went looking for
something else to give them their lives
meaning instead of kicking back and
saying we got through the Cold War it
ended without a cataclysm let's relax
for a while just this morning I was
reading Bill Kristol complaint with Hugh
Hewitt that right now with the British
Parliament voting against intervention
in Syria that were just living through
the 30s Oliver tell me they brought up
the the the Oxford Union vote yeah no
doubt okay well I thought was a stirring
moment yesterday vote in the house
Prime Minister gets outputted shift of
seven votes would have he would have won
and he looks across the chamber and says
the government will act accordingly
what does it say that our former
monarchist overlords are showing more
kind of democratic leanings on elections
it shows that the iraq syndrome the
successor to the Vietnam syndrome may be
more durable than the Vietnam syndrome
was that is people are still getting
over that Vietnam was a mistake about
nation-building and about the domino
effect and all the rest but in the
context of the Cold War you can sort of
understand that what makes the made the
Iraq war so interesting was the clarity
of the failure of intelligence the man
who must be dreading today's argument
about serious Colin Powell because
people are going to go back and run the
guts go to the videotape and we're gonna
see him presenting in complete sincerity
bad information to the United Nations
what is what was the mistake or was it a
series that just kept getting worse the
the intelligence was wrong that the u.s.
acted on but then the war plan I get
well actually I guess the war plan was
pretty successful I mean we were able to
invade and take you know get the bag
that very quickly but then it's clear
there was no operational plan after that
and then we just compiled more and more
errors both in Afghanistan well the head
of our military establishment the time
Don Rumsfeld didn't well stay there he
said I want to get rid of Saddam Hussein
hand the keys over to the Iraqi people
and leave well the Iraqi people barely
exist as a people turns out there are
lots of different Iraqis they don't like
each other very much regime should be
understood the way Aristotle did regime
is an entire culture of politics and
assumptions and values and mores and
customs and dispositions once you
understand regime that way you begin to
realize that regime change is
preposterous just as nation-building as
preposterous makes no more sense to talk
about nation-building notice I've got
orchid building orchids or organic
things so our nation's actually that's
how we got in trouble with with Iraq we
thought we'd go in and change the folks
behind the desk and you would
effectively change Iraq when the
Japanese government went to Admiral
Yamamoto and said could you take
stealthily a fleet across the North
Pacific and deliver a devastating attack
on the American fleet in Hawaii Yamamoto
supposedly city I can do that and I will
run wild in the Pacific for six months
maybe a year but then what
that's the question people forget desc
Yamamoto had lived in the United States
he loved the United States he'd been
military attache in Washington been to
Harvard amazingly he still loved the
United States and he knew that what they
would accomplish with pearl harbors to
enrage a continental superpower
it was not going to end well and it
didn't when we talked about regime
change in Iraq we could say oh yeah all
Iraq needs are three people they needed
George Washington a unifying figure
above politics they need a James Madison
a genius at the architecture of getting
factions to live together they need an
Alexander Hamilton who understands the
political economy of a large society and
oh by the way yes they need the
political culture from which such people
sprang it's that part that we neglected
we undertook regime change in our
country and we did it in the American
South we started at Appomattox in April
1865 and reconstruction had a long
elapse with Jim Crow and with litigation
demonstrations all the rest we really
affected regime change as Aristotle
would understand it by the late 70s what
you say a hundred and ten years I was
gonna say you're just saying that it's
too soon to issue a verdict on Iraq no
it's not no because the pressure won't
be kept on them I mean now at the same
time I mean and and the case in foreign
policy maybe it's easier to see the idea
that you can just overnight rip up one
you know take out one society or one
culture and put a new one in that also
makes sense in an American context and
yet at the same time you have
increasingly kind words for the what
used to be derided by conservatives as
judicial activism why does it make sense
for the Supreme Court to or judges at
various levels to really kind of step in
and say no this is the way we're going
to do it and to invalidate legislative
decision first of all someone has to say
what the Constitution means and and the
final arbiter everyone is responsible
for deciding presidents are behaving
properly when they veto legislation on
constitutional grounds so everyone's
involved in this
and it used to be until fairly recently
in American history as about the 60s the
the threshold question before Congress
acted was do we have the power to act in
this area with this kind of measure
James Q Wilson the greatest social
scientists of his generation said that
the crucial moment may have been 1965
and the Elementary and Secondary
Education Act is when they passed that
you the legitimacy barrier had
completely fallen there was no such
thing in what way
there was no said no subject that it was
not legitimate for the federal
government to legislate about just gone
at that point I when I was at Princeton
and graduate school 64 through 67 I was
one of the earlier recipients of federal
aid for graduate students you know it
was called National Defense Education
Act the interstate highway system was a
National Defense highway system now they
may have been stretching things the
point is that was a healthy reflex there
they said that we're attaching what
we're doing to an enumerated power the
Constitution now why should judges
beyond that if anyone is going to vivify
the theory that we have a government of
limited delegated and enumerated powers
it will be the judges because there's no
incentive for the legislature to
restrain itself but beyond that the
threshold question is this does America
exist to preserve freedom or to
implement majority rules and is this the
I mean I assume that that's the theme of
your dissertation actually correct it
we'll get to that just a second the most
important word in the Declaration of
Independence is secure all men are
created equal endowed by their creator
certain animal rights to protect those
rights or that governments are
instituted among men to secure those
rights not to give us our rights the
rights pre-exists government
and governments exist to secure that
which exists without their help
governments are important to secure them
but not as Fountains of rights and that
means that democracy and majority rule
is valid because and to the extent that
it protects freedom but then we you know
that's where the argument begins right
because for instance you have written
recently in this year critical of gay
marriage or what we would call marriage
equality if government exists to secure
certain rights and it should be treating
people as individuals why wouldn't that
clearly indicate that two men or two
women should be allowed to marry with
all the privileges that the state
secures well I it's this argument at
this point is to be highly
unsatisfactory because we're arguing
about the name I mean even people who
say we want to deny that word marriage
to this or all for civil unions with the
full panoply of social rights and
entitlements so it's it's frankly it's
not an argument that interests me very
much other than to say that it's helped
some of our liberal friends rediscover
federalism we now have blue state
federalism people saying huh that's a
good idea
marijuana but let Colorado decide and
marriage good Californians see what
happens and so it's been an educational
moment for our friends marijuana
federalism you wrote a couple of really
interesting columns I think last year
talking about your own kind of
rethinking of where our drug laws are
where incarceration the kind of problem
of over incarceration in this country
right now where are you right now when
it comes to you know should people be
arrested for smoking pot or selling it
well my first point is I want a couple
states - I want various states to try
various regimes let's see what happens I
mean one in eight Americans lives in
California that's a big laboratory and
let's see what happens out there and
Colorado is going through all kinds of
difficult
yeah unanticipated questions arise
workplace safety what about driving when
you're using a controlled but legal
substance all the rest let's figure it
out by having little experiments to the
extent that our drug laws are driving
mass incarceration which is a national
scandal and a huge national waste of
money and a huge assault on the social
fabric because everyone who goes to jail
almost everyone who goes just coming out
coming home back to the neighborhood and
it's not coming home improved by the
experience to that extent to the extent
that the drug laws are tangled up in all
the rest they need a radical rethinking
yet for me the most interesting text
that you've written in the past several
years was the preface that you you gave
to a new Princeton University edition of
get Barry Goldwater's conscience of a
conservative one of the things you
talked about in that which i think is
apropos of the current moment and
conservative thought is that you said in
the early 1950s when the conservative
movement started getting cooking that it
was remarkably bookish and there you
know there were people like TS Eliot
strains like that Russell Kirk and you
said that you know that these were
strains that were flavored by religion
nostalgia and resistance to the
permanent revolution of conditions in a
capitalist market society and you said
that it had Barry Goldwater been a
reading man he would have he would have
found these forms of conservative
unintelligible even repellent is Barry
Goldwater the model for where what you
are now calling conservativism
I want more Goldwater ISM in the mix
what are the benefits or what you know
what are the the strong suits of
Goldwater that are that are missing in
today well it's the basic skepticism
about state action it is it's the
Southwest open horizon multicultural
society you know he's a great
photographer Barry and he loved
photographing Native Americans and he
lived among people of Hispanic origin
who've been there a lot longer than the
Goldwater said men goldwater's came from
Poland I think and when they got to the
southwest they were newcomers so he had
like this kind of live and let live open
spaces a lot of sunlight just wonderful
spirit in the southwest that I happen to
love I want more of the Goldwater
impulse and there's also an optimism
friendliness and optimism because it was
actually kind of stunning when you said
earlier that you participate in
technological innovation or you at least
recognize it what you know at what point
does the does that take over in terms of
you know why are we still talking about
government because as long as we can go
to on the internet and get whatever song
we want are we wasting our time by even
focusing on government no because the
government can be an impediment to this
we want the government to get out of the
way and we want the government to do
certain kinds of research that because
of the time horizons on the research the
private sector is not going to do Bell
Labs doesn't do it anymore
used to may be good it may be true but
they're not you're gonna you're in favor
of for instance what you call basic
scientific yes I would double the NIH is
about you know I'd spend more on certain
things but I've visited Goldwater at his
home several times he built this home on
a little bluff overlooking the valley
where Phoenix is and he said he built a
home where he used to sleep at night
he'd ride his horse up and sleep at
night in this little spot where
house was built at that time he said
there are a hundred thousand people in
the valley now we're approaching four
million now this is a man who had to be
comfortable with change and dynamism as
you know I'm sure the greatest him to
capitalism ever written is in the
Communist Manifesto Karl Marx says
everything disappears into thin air and
there is that that's European
conservatives have never come to terms
of that American conservatives have we
kind of like that and yet the goldwater
tendency has never really been the
dominant one or the most successful one
in the Republican Party what's what's
the opposite of Goldwater ISM now who
embodies that and I don't know I don't
think you some people said well there's
the establishment I don't think there is
a Republican establishment the
Republican establishment death can be
dated for the front of it in 1966 from
the New York Herald Tribune died there
was a time when they had their newspaper
that was the Republican establishment
newspaper the Republican establishment
Bank with Chase Manhattan you had Nelson
and David Rockefeller they could get to
the Goldwater convention in San
Francisco in 64 and conger arrival
nominee and Bill Scranton out of thin
air they were they were four there no
Republican establishment anymore which
is good but there are countervailing
forces and figures who don't have that
kind of live and let live southwestern
ethos who don't anymore have that kind
of skepticism of government what
happened or why why did that did those
values become ascendant in conservatism
well the the conservatives who are in
elective office are looking over their
shoulder had a deeply conflicted
electorate and again it's the cognitive
dissonance the American people
rhetorically are Jeffersonians
operationally they're hamiltonians
and squaring that circle is a difficult
challenge for political operatives that
Romney tried to square the circle by
saying you know I'm a good Republican
and I'm never going to tell you anything
that I'm going to cut ever because I
don't want to scare you and people found
him inauthentic what what did you see as
him is sort of the as a face of
conservatism
well I he was he's not the face of
conservatism he's a he's a northeastern
big business creative capitalist who
wanted to govern for a while honorable
man intelligent man a man of great
accomplishments tremendous personal
decency but he wasn't a political man in
the sense that he had an idea that
America has serious problems that ought
to be addressed in 2016
who-who D where do you see the choice in
the in the country being between and not
necessarily Republican and Democrat but
you know what what is the choice that we
have to make a decision about there that
is going to actually allow us to start
addressing the operational cognitive
dissonance in the American population I
think the American people feel today
that the system isn't working for them
and I think they're largely right I
think what they have not internalized is
that big government is invariably
primarily a servant of the strong of the
organized the educated the affluent the
lawyered up
that's why Washington is what it is
today and that's why we get Medicaid
prescription drugs for exactly this is
the old law of concentrated benefits and
dispersed costs and it's a kind of
constant shell game
two-thirds of the federal budget today
is transfer payments so transfer
payments are twice as big as everything
else the Marine Corps the National Parks
the FBI everything so everyone's on the
take as it were and the challenge for
conservatives and the challenge
particularly for libertarian flavored
conservatism is to maneuver within the
public's complete conflicted desires you
talk about 2016 my first rule is I want
a governor I don't want any more
senators they've never run anything they
don't they really believe in the magic
of words Scott Walker Kasich Mike Pence
Bobby Jindal people have actually had to
run things and had people clamorous
people in their outer office the
American people are now living with and
more comfortable than they want to admit
a big state and we're not going back
we're just not I'd like to go back to it
Robert Jay knock wanted but we're not
going what our but I mean you by the
same token you and you've talked about
kind of economic determinism or the idea
that people think that the way things
are going now is the only way they can
go and in fact in various periods in
American history that just radically
changes you know Medicare at this point
if you know if you throw in Social
Security as well I mean we're on Oh
deaths we're in a death spiral are there
ways to pull out of that that are not
going to be so disruptive as to cause
even more social upheaval President
Obama says to Paul Ryan Paul Ryan would
end Medicare as we know it arithmetic
will end Medicare as we know it this is
not a surprise and it's not optional
it's gonna end questions then what do we
do then what Yamamoto's quest
again so Republicans have to be ready as
the crisis nears I don't want to sound
like this conservative Marxism the
internal contributions become in support
you have a I mean in the Goldwater
preface you talk a lot about a bit kind
of dialectic yeah and I mean do you see
in a sense then I mean and this might
bring it back to the concept of a
libertarian moment that what we're
seeing now is the dialectic shifting
away from a kind of expanse of
government across all ideologies to to
its opposite right in part because when
I come back to the technological part
people are conditioned by their daily
experience going to Starbucks going on
the Internet to the sense of empowerment
and the idea that some people here in
Washington are gonna fix 18% of the
economy that's the health care system by
writing rules and regulations just
strikes young people as weird just
doesn't make any sense and that's a sea
change can we perhaps wrap things up by
telling us how Everett Dirksen's
untimely death changed george will's
life well I was teaching at the
University of Toronto I was two years
out of Princeton graduate school and in
the fall of 1969 Everett Dirksen died in
the great state of Illinois where I am
from and Dirksen had been the leader of
the Republicans in the Senate and so
they had to vote and shuffled leadership
and a Colorado Republican Gordon a lot
of whom I'd never heard became third
ranking Republican chairman of the
policy committee he said to one of his
staff I would like to hire a Republican
academic to write for me it was 1969
there were no public and academics
except me and I was in Canada through
serendipity a guy at the University of
Denver had been in graduate school at
Princeton with me said to Gordon Allen I
know a guy is really weird conservative
and so they got me down here
so if if Dirksen had lived a few years
longer I would have got tenure and
teaching somewhere
do you regret moving back down into the
United States and I wasn't alone no no
no hopeless
nationalist and would want to live here
and I've had a wonderful time in
Washington I think I'll let the shorts
anomalous over theater life she said
I've had a wonderful life I just wish
I'd realized it at the time well I'm
having a wonderful time in Washington I
realize it every day because they in
part I know that my current happiness to
Barack Obama who is so aggressively
progressive so thoroughly concentrates
all the American progressive tradition
and the academic culture that goes with
it that he's really put the spring in my
step just in opposition you had a great
line earlier this year I think it was
that the modern liberalism the whole
point of it is to make people feel good
about themselves which which struck me
as being kind of true is do you feel
like that's kind of the epitome of Obama
ISM and the way that politics have been
waged and in fact the way the 2012
election was sort of actually fought
over as opposed to the actual issues
yeah we now have a lot of data they say
it's anecdotal one answered the plural
of anecdote is data about affirmative
action we know it's really not helping
people through lis hurting a lot of
people the way we're administering it
doesn't matter to the advocates of
affirmative action because the point of
affirmative action is to make them feel
good it's to make these we make the
administrators of a make a university
make elite universities feel virtuous
and the fact that well there's abundant
evidence that for example the way the
major law schools the elite law schools
in California are administering
affirmative action
reducing the number of african-american
lawyers in California don't care because
that's not what this is about it's about
feeling good
it even seeps over into foreign policy I
mean the reason we went to worry in or
at least over Libya but Mays feel good
it was a it was a moral gesture with
high explosives that and then we packed
up and went home except for the people
we left in Benghazi in in terms of kind
of racial questions or racial dynamics
in America you recently are you're fond
of actually pointing out how when Daniel
Moynihan wrote the Moynihan report what
was the the level of illegitimate 23.7%
right and now it's it's tougher to for
black Americans here's a question for
you in related to policy you know it
it's also much higher among the white
white births all births it doesn't seem
like anything it's ever gonna go back
down you know to what it was in the
sixties I was considered well then what
how do you affect that and I this might
be a question it's a craft insult that's
a good question because we don't know
what caused this we've seen family
disintegration in war famine pestilence
this happened in peacetime high in
prosperity we've seen this sea change of
mores I don't know what caused it and
until you know what caused it's hard to
know how you address it but what we're
seeing and what charles murray addresses
in his book coming apart is a bifurcate
dangerous bifurcation of american
society we're in sort of traditional
bourgeois morality norms of marriage and
family obtained among the high achievers
and because the family is the primary
transmitter of social capital they will
continue to reproduce themselves whereas
down lower these norms among the people
who most need the accumulated so
capital of a family represents our doing
the most damage to the family and i
think charles murray says that he wishes
that the upper classes those who said
the cultural tone of the country would
preach what they practice but i I don't
I I think there are corrective
mechanisms in society you know there was
a great problem in 18th century London
when the surplus of grain and the in the
Western world combined with the new art
of distilling in a producer gin and I
produced the London of hogarth terrible
ravages social costs of alcohol well
they did the government research didn't
licensing laws closed the pubs a bit I
didn't what changed it what changed it
was John Wesley
John Wesley gave 30,000 speak sermons
and he converted the women of Agnon and
the women brought the men to heal and
England healed and pretty soon you had
the Victorian era things were different
so things can change but it's not it's
largely cultural ferment cultural dry I
don't again getting into marks in
language here but politics can be an
epic phenomenon when hopes that it is
because otherwise we're totally screwed
well it's it's it's epic phenomenal
often but not always we talked a lot
about things that are kind of trending
in a bad direction are you optimistic
still despite everything yeah I think so
because the American premises are quite
correct
and the American capacity for renewal is
real we live in a city here in
Washington that was segregated 40 years
ago
look at the change in this country
breathtaking take just shocking behavior
that was normal the routine daily
insulting of America african-americans
by white Americans now completely
unacceptable that's astonishing
improvement in laws here I have to say
to my libertarian friends laws mattered
here I said we're doing Goldwater is the
one who said you know that you can't you
can change the laws but you can't make
me love my neighbor but in fact he's
probably wrong about that that's right
and and - it's the answer was a you'd be
surprised and B even if you can't love
him you can sit at the lunch counter
with them and say pass the sugar and you
do that enough things change and they
did so that the plasticity of America is
still wonderful you know you look at all
the battle dick torian's in California
high school named Rodriguez and no Yin
it's it's the premises are right and a
final word about the capacity for
renewal we have a wonderfully
retrospective cast to our politics we
always look back to the basic documents
the Declaration and the Constitution the
best most renewing thing that's happened
in America
in the last four or five years called
the tea party it's named after something
that happened in 1773 for pete's sake I
mean this it's a very healthy the way we
go through life with a crick in our neck
from looking back at our origins which
are in a doctrine of limited delegated
and enumerated powers for the government
that's why I'm confident and I think we
will leave it there thank you so much
for talking at length with us George
well talking with Matt Welch and Nick
Gillespie for reason TV thanks very much